that we all want to believe that through
some component we can buy into a lottery
and change our lives that's the entire
pitch behind the lottery
my concerns around crypto or Bitcoin as
it's being presented today is that the
emphasis is on that on the idea of
wealth creation as compared to utility
but what I'm not excited about is the
rank speculation and you know what I
would argue is fraudulent selling to
retail of here's the keys to how you get
rich simply by buying something and I
got to tell you very few tiers are being
shed right now for my lack of
participation in the Bitcoin Network or
the ethereum network we're social
creatures when you think about the
behavior in the Bitcoin marketing story
it was all designed to appeal to the
fear that we have of being left behind
when you hear somebody say have fun
staying poor that's not the future of
Finance
that's somebody trying to trigger your
fear of being left behind this is the
future of Finance well how much is the
future of Finance work that seems like a
lot I'm going to go that's a big number
right
because Bitcoin is programmatically
limited in terms of the number of
Bitcoins that'll ever be produced that
means at some point in the future the
system has to collapse
thank you
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourist get trapped in a tube
door
that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you thank you
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew Dawes
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and this is
a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
our brilliant guest today is the chief
strategist and the portfolio manager for
simplify Asset Management in the US Mike
Green welcome to trigonometry thank you
Constantine I appreciate it uh no
worries it's so good to have you on the
show before we get into it tell
everybody a little bit about who you are
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here talking to us
uh well I had asked you actually the
exact same question before we got
started but
um I have been an investor in uh mutual
funds hedge funds and now ETFs the Fermi
and the chief strategist for simplify
asset management is an ETF firm based in
the United States
um I've been doing this for about 30
years and what I'm most well known for
is the work that I've done around
derivative structures alternative
Investments like crypto or Bitcoin and
in particular uh the opportunities that
you can the opportunities that investors
have to incorporate those types of
investments into their portfolios to
improve returns over time
well it's great to have you on the show
uh I the main reason we wanted to talk
with you is uh Bitcoin and crypto
because we've had uh one or two people
on the show who are very enthusiastic
about it we've also had one or two
people who are less enthusiastic and I
know that you have some skepticism not
necessarily about Bitcoin or crypto
itself but about the way it's been
marketed and promoted so uh you know
when I if I open my Twitter account uh
it's gonna be about three messages down
before there's a hot girl talking about
how you should put all your savings into
crypto immediately uh to to to make your
life better and to have better sex and
and whatever else it is that that
Bitcoin offers everybody allegedly uh
what's wrong with that
well it sounds like my settings are on
my Twitter are wrong because I I've
blocked all those people but
um
there's a couple of things I think that
are really important to understand as it
relates to crypto or Bitcoin the first
is
um behind any form of narrative or
marketing pitch that has to be an
element of truth right and so people are
understandably very frustrated and very
upset at the levels of intervention in
monetary policy the perception that the
system is stacked against them and
something like Bitcoin that is quote
unquote performed extraordinarily well
where the price has risen to the point
the people who made relatively small
Investments have experienced
life-changing degrees of wealth is
naturally seductive to people right that
we all want to believe that through some
component we can buy into a lottery and
change our lives that's the entire pitch
behind the lottery
my concerns around crypto or Bitcoin is
this being presented today is that the
emphasis is on that on the idea of
wealth creation as compared to utility
right
trying to make people money instead of
trying to help people make money in one
form or another
and the reason that you're talking to me
is as I got involved in debates around
Bitcoin sometime in early 2021 as I
increasingly began to hear from my
clients the language that had somewhat
become Universal which is it's the
dominant trade right it's the only trade
that makes sense in the environment that
was there that was fully embraced both
within the institutional community and
it was embraced certainly within the
retail community that this was an
opportunity to buy something that was
simply going to make you rich simply by
virtue of buying it right now in many
ways it's important to identify that
that type of identification something
that makes you money without you having
to do anything other than buying it by
definition is a security and therefore
it passes What's called the Howie test
therefore you end up in this very
uncomfortable position as you've tried
to explain to people well the math
behind that actually doesn't work right
so what Bitcoin really is is it is
compensation that is paid to the
accounting firms that manage the
database behind Bitcoin the database is
called the blockchain the accounting
firms are called the miners and all
they're doing is is they're performing
very complicated but ultimately
pointless math to compete to build the
next block in that blockchain right it
is what's called a proof of work system
the idea of mining is similar to you
getting down with your pickaxe and
knocking away little pieces of rock in
order to generate gold right
but at the end of the day what you're
paying for is the accounting system in
Bitcoin now that accounting system could
actually be valuable in and of itself
and again it is valuable in the context
of what Bitcoin was originally designed
to be which is a peer-to-peer payment
system it allowed people to avoid the
rails of the banking system and to
conduct transactions and in turn the
work that was done around accounting
allowed those transactions to be proved
right that's actually a really
interesting and important observation
what it has morphed into is a
speculative asset in which people are
competing to buy in the secondary Market
this token what we call Bitcoin that is
used to compensate the miners
very few people understand that this way
the system is set up ultimately requires
a continual inflow of the the
pejoratively named fiat currency right
dollars pounds
um Euros Etc you need to actually have a
continuous flow of money into the
Bitcoin Network in order to keep that
accounting system robust and in order to
keep people doing it right so it sounds
like a pyramid scheme that's what I was
going to say isn't that very much a
pyramid Ponzi scheme until actual
utility emerges right so retail
transactions people's decision to buy or
sell something on that accounting
Network could actually theoretically
create value in the same way that the
Visa Network creates value for Visa
shareholders right we could have moved
in that direction But ultimately we
failed to do so because we became so
enamored of the speculation around the
value of the token itself
it's actually a really important
distinction whether the network itself
had value as a payment mechanism which
it very clearly did for money launderers
for those who were in you know third
world countries and trying to evade
punitive banking systems and punitive
government Behavior
absolutely has value in in those areas
but that's where it stopped it never
turned into a robust payment system for
the rest of us it never turned into a
robust peer-to-peer transfer system for
the vast majority of people instead it
became a bunch of speculative nonsense
very interesting and you know what I
think instinctively Francis and I are
both kind of small C conservative when
it comes to money because when we looked
at Bitcoin it was always that feeling of
like this is a bubble that that's that's
going to burst probably many times uh
because of the speculative element of it
but let me ask you a different question
I know this is sidetracking the
conversation slightly but it's I can
tell you you really understand these
things uh deeply uh there's a lot of
people who are not hot girls on Twitter
who are really excited about blockchain
as a technology can you explain to us
what it is and why reasonable people are
excited about that part of it
um so there are elements of blockchain
that are actually very valuable right so
or elements behind the thought process
which is is that instead of having to
trust the single holder of record for
example Visa saying yes we show that you
made this transaction
right instead of having to rely on visa
to accurately capture that information
and accurately report it to me in other
words be a trusted intermediary
blockchain takes the idea of that
database and spreads it out over anyone
who wants to participate right what's
called running a node effectively
everybody gets to audit all of the
transactions that are occurring when
they happen on chain in other words
going through that accounting system
there's some interesting components of
that because the removal of trust from a
system establishes a component of a
transactions a series of transactions of
record that are very hard for people to
argue against and very hard for people
to change right now that can actually
have value and there are many situations
in which that becomes quite interesting
unfortunately the blockchain technology
as it exists today is largely way too
slow and way too Limited in order to
accommodate all the transactions that
people are claiming it's useful for
right so that process that process of
um Distributing that database inherently
makes it very slow right it's like
trying to do work where you're
constantly seeking consensus right we've
all been parts of organizations where
meetings are the primary form of
activity and everybody tries to come to
consensus and we recognize that nothing
really interesting gets done
that's very much where blockchain is
today it's just inherently quite slow
some second and third generation
blockchain Technologies are beginning to
emerge that allow this concept of a
distributed database with limited areas
of trust that actually become quite
robust and quite interesting and again
there has to be an element of Truth in
order to get people to buy into
something to get people to participate
in a scheme right if I were to turn
around and tell people something
completely absurd like the sky is purple
and therefore the world is going to end
tomorrow people could very simply look
at the sky and say well it's not purple
therefore this guy's an idiot they may
choose to say that independently the
that Dynamic of having an element of
Truth is really critical and there are a
lot of Truths Behind this idea of
digitization of documents this idea of
digitally native Securities I often show
people I don't happen to have it on my
desk right now but I you know my mother
purchased for my children's stock
certificates physical stock certificates
right now ironically what this means is
that I receive as the shareholder of
record for these shares I receive one
penny dividend checks right checks
written out in my name for one penny
which drive my wife completely insane
and I'm forced to cash at a cost to the
system of probably several dollars it
costs about 85 cents to write and check
and process a check and that check is
being sent to me for one penny right now
that's completely absurd but it's
reflective of the analog nature of the
Securities industry there continues to
be an over Reliance on paper records
that's true for your mortgage that's
true for stock certificate that's true
for Bond certificates Etc all of this
stuff doesn't truly exist in digital
form that places limitations on a lot of
things that we should be able to do that
we currently can't do right I'll give
another simple example most of your
viewers would be familiar with the movie
The Big Short and the idea of
securitization of mortgages right part
of the reason why securitization is this
fancy special word is it to build a
residential mortgage-backed security
that's securitization requires on
average some around 3 million paper
documents to be held and physically
maintained by the the issuer of that
piece of paper
right wow that's kind of crazy when you
think about it in the 21st century but
it is a legal requirement if we were to
move everything to truly digitally
native Securities Not only would I be
able to do that individually because I
no longer have to hold three million
paper documents in a storage facility
somewhere but I can also start to attach
all sorts of interesting features to
that in which various performance
components various distribution Dynamics
the waterfall that was described so well
in that movie The Big Short all of those
can be embedded in things we call Smart
contracts your viewers again would be
familiar with those terms so like I'm
incredibly excited about that world
but what I'm not excited about is the
rank speculation and you know what I
would argue is fraudulent selling to
retail of here's the keys to how you get
rich simply by buying something right
everything I just described involves me
creating something you know changing the
system significantly so that more people
have access to the ability to create new
stuff and do new things
that's a very exciting world
one who just ranked speculation
you know to me just feeds the frauds
that we've seen and we're now seeing
those of course come home to roost
Francis before you jump in can I
disagree with you Mike I reckon if you
said the sky is purple and the world's
about to collapse in the current age
there's a lot of people who would go
along with that but anyway Francis
by the way I actually agree with you I
would probably capture a reasonable cult
sized Following over the Internet that
would allow me to sell them anything
going forward but yeah go ahead
but so that being the case what is the
difference as far as you're concerned if
there's any difference between Bitcoin
and the rest of crypto like ethereum Etc
um so I think that there that there is
actually functionally very little
difference they are at the end of the
day they're just algorithms that set a
certain protocol for Behavior right so
Bitcoin as I mentioned is really just a
token that is compensating people who
are doing accounting for the Bitcoin
system
ethereum now that it's moved to what's
referred to as proof of stake as
compared to proof of work is moving to a
slightly different Dynamic where the
ethereum token is actually a requirement
similar to posting US dollars as
collateral it's a requirement for
posting collateral on the ethereum
network
right so
um I I don't think that there's actually
that much difference they're all
protocols that are basically just code
the question is what is the utility of
that code what is the utility of that
protocol
ethereum has its flaws it has
significant flaws and ultimately I'm
somewhat skeptical about whether it will
end up winning or not but it it at least
attempts to make things useful right
things like the introduction of smart
contracts the introduction of proof of
stake where the use of proof of stake
that basically says I'm willing to run
the risk of losing x amount of ethereum
tokens or US Dollars
Etc if this turns out not to work right
so I'm basically putting my money where
my mouth is in that process that's again
quite different than the Dynamics of
speculation as to whether or not Bitcoin
is going up in price or down in price
which makes me very sad right
um you know those radically different
components ethereum is theoretically
designed for building the biggest
challenge that you have in ethereum is
that it is again relatively slow and
relatively high cost at this point
so Mike there was a period I remember
during the pandemic I think it was 2021
where all of these crypto spiked
and then it suddenly crashed can you
explain to us what actually happened was
it that people lost confidence
or what is it was there something else
going on
so there there is something else going
on and this is actually this overlaps
with the work that I do in broader
markets um what you're actually
describing is a byproduct of a system
that exhibits a economic property called
inelasticity right so you can think of
elasticity like rubber band right things
are very flexible they change a lot most
models of markets assume a high degree
of elasticity in other words for
significant changes in supply and demand
price doesn't change all that much
inelastic system is one in which the
price changes a lot for small changes in
supply and demand
in the case of something like Bitcoin
that has a fixed issuance schedule right
so you've heard terms like the halving
of Bitcoin Etc the supply is fixed a
continuous Supply is generated of new
Bitcoin that is available the existing
supply of Bitcoin doesn't change
therefore an increase in demand
ends up causing a significant increase
in price right
we can run through this model very
quickly you know Francis let's pretend
that you and I are effectively the
market for Bitcoin right I own Bitcoin
you want to buy Bitcoin offer to buy my
Bitcoin
uh yeah I will offer you fifteen
thousand dollars for one Bitcoin no
I'm huddling I'm not gonna sell to you
now you have to get Bitcoin you've told
your investors you're going to get
Bitcoin you're an Institutional Investor
that just launched a Bitcoin fund you
need that Bitcoin come on bid up
uh so I'll offer you eighteen thousand
dollars for one bit no I'm not selling
it to you keep going
um okay 22k
yeah that's not anywhere close to the
right answer let's keep going up I'll
sell you one for twenty thousand
okay so here we go that's actually what
ends up happening is exactly that
most people choose to refuse to sell as
that new demand comes into the market
prices exhibit inelasticity in other
words rise significantly that increase
in price in turn lets people think oh my
gosh something really valuable must be
going on here why would I sell I'm
actually incentivized now to hoddle
right I th these guys are right Bitcoin
is going to go to a million
right and then suddenly
um Constantine shows up and spoils the
Party by saying well gosh I got some
Bitcoin at 12 back in 2011 at 22 000
I'll sell some
okay now the story is over the price
begins to collapse
right that's exactly what happened in
2021 and it was try it was tied to the
growth of the institutional story this
Dynamic that I was referring to before
Bitcoin is the dominant trade it's the
best of the inflation trades right
number go up
that phenomenon is what we experienced
in 2021
because there were so many people Mike
and who were Evangelical about this who
were saying you know this is the future
of currency this is you know if you
you've got to jump on the Bitcoin train
now if you don't you're missing out and
then it collapsed do you think that
we've kind of seen the end of Bitcoin as
the as you know as the way they marketed
it as a future of currency or do you
think it's still got somewhere to go
so I hope that it's over
um I think unfortunately it was a
fundamentally flawed theory that
propelled its growth and its adoption
this idea that you could replace States
in terms of the states meaning
governments in terms of the role of
currency right so this is part of what
my early debates on bitcoin tried to
educate people on is is what money
actually is as crazy as it sounds money
is a byproduct of debt money is the
legal tender that is used to cancel debt
contracts
right that's what it actually means and
so Mike explain that for the ordinary
person because I think for most people
that'd be quite confusing so if you look
at a US dollar and I can't speak to a
British pound because I don't know the
answer to this and I'll have one
directly in front of me it has the same
statement I know that's the same
statement this is the you know this is
legal tender for all debts public and
private
the ultimate debt that is created is the
government saying you have to pay taxes
only thing that will accept for the
payment in taxes is the US dollar the
British pound the Euro Etc
right the minute you actually make that
statement as a government and as a
government you have the Monopoly on
force that allows you to say if you
didn't pay your taxes I'm going to put
you into this thing we call jail
right that suddenly creates demand for
the currency people have a reason that
they need it Render unto Caesar what is
Caesars right that is really what is
going on with currency
it is declared as legal tender for debts
both public and private within that
Circle of the Monopoly of violence right
where the government controls the
resources that allow you to enforce this
whether this is a court system or the
physical army or anything else right
that's what currency actually is it is
that which cancels debt there is no
native Bitcoin debt there is no native
ethereum debt there is no mechanism for
enforcement other than saying you can't
participate in the Bitcoin Network or
the ethereum network and I got to tell
you very few tiers are being shed right
now for my lack of participation in the
Bitcoin Network or the ethereum network
because there's almost nothing useful I
can do on them other than money
laundering drug dealing various forms of
sex trafficking Etc right now I
understand how offensive that feels to
the person who has transferred money to
their relative in a developing country
or the person in a developing country
that has used the Bitcoin Network to
Shield their hard-earned savings from an
abusive government right those
situations do exist but understand one
person's Freedom Fighter is another
person's terrorist if you're using the
Bitcoin Network to hide money from your
government you're breaking the law
I'm not going to State you know make a
statement as to the moral
appropriateness of this if you happen to
be in Lebanon or Iraq or anywhere else
right like pick your poison many places
have terrible governance but this is a
way of skirting the law and in developed
countries like the United States or the
UK or Europe right
that's law breaking and you should
expect it to be treated as such
well that's one of the things that I
always as someone who's not an expert by
any means in this era I sort of heard
people running around and going well you
know crypto allows you to sort of take
government out of the the thing I was
like death and taxes like the
government's going to get involved no
matter what you you can build whatever
you want the government will find a way
to tax it and to control it
um speaking of government one of the
other thing I hear things I hear the the
sort of crypto enthusiasts talking about
a lot is these big scary digital
currencies that the governments are
working on can you shed some light onto
those and what those are about sure so
what you're referring to a central bank
digital currencies Yes again addressing
this idea that the system that we have
right now is analog right it's not
digital and it's underlying construction
a move to Central Bank digital
currencies is both an opportunity and a
threat and the reason why I say that is
from an opportunity standpoint it
creates all sorts of functionality like
what we're referring to right so if each
token which is what the US dollar or
British pound is referred to is natively
digital and basically built into the
system so that it's constructed as such
each use of that token in turn is going
to natively be in that digital system
and open up all the opportunities that
we were talking about before right you
as an individual could securitize your
own mortgage for example right now I'm
not suggesting that's necessarily going
to happen but that type of opportunity
would exist
the the issue with digital currencies as
done by central banks is that they also
represent extraordinary risks of privacy
intrusion it creates the opportunity for
the government to do things to the money
that you think of as being in your to
steal from the crypto phrase cold wallet
right that thing we have in our pocket
where I've got physical paper
certificates
the government traditionally was limited
in their ability to debase or reduce the
value of that by conducting centralized
activities right they want to reduce the
value of the dollar I have in my wallet
the only way they can do that is by
large-scale printing of dollars that are
then distributed from this you know from
the government right that has an
indirect effect
when you move to that digital Dynamic
you actually open up the risk that if I
do something the government doesn't like
they literally reach into my wallet and
take that money away from me
now that's a very scary proposition it's
also a very scary proposition to think
about the potential for the government
to monitor every single transaction that
I do
right and this is actually my biggest
complaint about cbdc's is that the
government appears to misunderstand the
opportunity and importance of having
anonymized transactions because they
don't actually respect the price signals
that it received it may be morally
repugnant that I choose to buy drugs or
that I choose to hire a prostitute or
that I choose to watch pornography but
that's actually the price signal that's
sent by those by that demand is actually
an important signal to the economy if we
choose to weigh down that price signal
through moral you know statements that
that's not okay I'm going to reduce your
social credit score by virtue of your
personal behavior in the privacy of your
own home that damages the signals that
are received by Society right it hurts
our society and it hurts the economy in
that process well how does it hurt our
society sorry oh I think it's incredibly
important that people are actually able
to convey signals of what they want
right that's what the Invisible Hand of
capitalism is all about
it you know I would hope that I've made
life choices that I'm not in a position
that I need to purchase drugs to deal
with the mental distress associated with
my day-to-day existence or to use
pornography or to hire a prostitute
but that's actually actually you know is
an incredibly important economic signal
that's coming through when people engage
in that behavior right I'm conveying a
system of wants that is actually very
valuable into the economy and can
encourage people to create less harmful
and more effective substitutes
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousand thousands of pounds
in legal fees the great thing about
expressvpn is that you don't need any
technical skills to set up just like
Francis fire up the app and it's one
button to connect One Tap on a button
was all it needed for my entire life to
disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
so moving on now we we've talked we've
spoke about the crash and obviously uh
the collapse I think is FTX and Sam
bankman fried
what happened there because we this was
a billion dollar company a crypto
exchange and overnight it lost all its
value and he went from being a
billionaire to literally owning nothing
how did how does that happen
well I I think it's effective altruism
isn't it
gave away all his money in the day
that was his plan all along wasn't it no
um
I I I think again it speaks to this
general question of what does what does
worth actually mean right and what is
True Value we often inhabit a world
where people say things like well gold
is money gold is real value well again
gold is really only valuable to the
extent that you can use the brick to hit
somebody over the head and steal their
wallet or food
right
um it historically had value because
governments designated as the mechanism
that could be used to pay those taxes
otherwise you went to jail or beaten
over the head by a soldier
um and had your food taken away right
um
this is the same game that we played
with Bitcoin when you talk about what is
the value of FTX there's two ways of
thinking about that value one is it has
an intrinsic cash flow associated with
it it is a profitable business that
provides goods and services that people
value and that the company is able to
provide at lower cost than what it sells
to the market right an Apple iPhone
would be an obvious example to something
like that where it's something that
people now increasingly treat as an
indispensable part of their daily
existence it cost them somewhere in the
neighborhood of 400 to manufacture and
they're able to sell it to us for
somewhere in the neighborhood of twelve
hundred dollars giving them margins of
around 65 percent right that math is
very straightforward and simple and if
they're able to repeat that over and
over and over again the company
generates a series of cash flows that I
as an investor can then consider worth a
certain amount right
another way to think about it and this
is the one that we've largely entered
into in the last give or take 15 to 20
years is the value of something is
simply a function of what somebody else
will pay for it
right now there could be any number of
reasons why people decide that they need
to buy something you've got a wonderful
poster behind you on the wall there are
scenarios in which your fans would
decide I have to have that poster right
I'm willing to pay a thousand dollars
for that poster there's things that you
could do that would potentially enhance
the value of it you could sign it you
could make it a limited edition of one
or a five or a ten and those would all
add potential potentially add value to
somebody who's interested in purchasing
it and being able to say look I have
this you know trigonometry you know uh
nft we'll call it right
um
that type of speculative Finance is what
drove the value of FTX
it's that other people wanted to buy it
other people wanted to get a piece of
Sam bankman freed and this was Venture
capitalists this was high net worth
individuals this was family offices all
of whom with very limited due diligence
stepped in to give money to Sam bankman
Freed at a valuation that created these
billions and billions of dollars once
he's exposed as a fraud
guess what nobody wants to give him
money anymore and that value collapses
and that's because there's no real value
there right he's not creating a product
there's no cash flow associated with it
like an iPhone
right
wow so my I I love how how brilliant you
are at explaining these what are to most
people complicated things in a very
simple way so let me riddle me this why
do all these capitalists Venture
capitalists and all these other people
and and so who deal with this every day
who are very smart certainly a lot
smarter than me
Etc why why do they buy into this [__]
because I wouldn't
well because they're smarter than you
um that was a joke
the the the unfortunate reality is I
mentioned that this has now been kind of
15 to 20 years in process and
potentially even longer than that
you know we have seen repeatedly that
the mechanisms that are in place for
rewarding individuals for the decisions
that they make reinforce that a venture
capitalist receives a percentage of the
excess returns that are generated over
and above the cost of the initial
investment so in an environment in which
people are encouraged to separate the
value of something from its cash flows
and instead treat it in some variant of
like well anything has value as long as
other people are willing to pay for it
what traditionally would be referred to
as the greater fool Theory or Ponzi
financing right when you've been
rewarded for that the institutions grow
up and flourish they reinforce that type
of behavior and that's very much where
we are unfortunately I would argue that
most Venture capitalists or many Venture
capitalists have not lived through a
cycle in which they have to critically
examine why did Google work why did
Microsoft work why did Apple work why
did Amazon work instead they've largely
been rewarded by the activities of those
companies that are now protecting their
modes so Google for example has
purchased over I believe it's 1500
companies over the last 15 years since
it went public largely not to you know
generate cash flows in those businesses
but to protect its existing Golden Goose
in Search and prevent competition from
emerging
right that's made it incredibly
profitable to build things and simply
have the threat of displacing Google
Google have the threat of making
Google's Core Business less attractive
by funding that they're creating
conditions under which for Google it's
just more profitable say you know forget
it I'll just buy it let's just make it
go away
Silicon Valley for the past 20 years
what so just coming back to uh the FTX
thing and the the the the fact that a
venture capitalist but am I hearing you
correctly that basically from a venture
capitalist perspective all they're doing
is essentially buying into this Ponzi
scheme on the basis that Ponzi schemes
can make you money in the short term and
they're gonna get a slice of that
Revenue basically correct with no
recourse against them if they don't
right if I sell that company to Google
the fact that it never generates
profitability that it quietly disappears
right and think about any number of
technology companies that have splashed
onto the excitement Pages you know let's
take obvious ones you know Yahoo and
Tumblr and all this sort of stuff that
ultimately end up having almost no value
whatsoever right once they're required
and purchased by something it doesn't
matter anymore I got my 20 carry
wow but that's pretty effed up man isn't
it it's a very messed up system and
again that truth the fact that the
system is effed up right a technical
term in finance
um that f'd up system creates and it
facilitates the narrative that people
have which is nothing has any value
nothing has any meaning nothing means
anything right and it's a huge societal
ill that people are not in a position to
critically examine these assumptions
we're social creatures when you think
about the behavior in the Bitcoin
marketing story it was all designed to
appeal to the fear that we have of being
left behind you're not gonna make it
right well why do the zebra herds all
turn right for the most part because
there's safety in a crowd
right some fraction of the population
I'm unfortunately in you know
structurally wired differently so that
my bias is to say hey wait a second why
is everybody turning right now in nature
that means I probably get eaten by a
lion
but I happen to inhabit a
regime in which I'm given the luxury of
critically examining many of these
things but most people just have not had
the training or skill set or
um interest to develop those
capabilities and I understand why I I
actually think it's incredibly important
that most people broadly do what they're
told
right and I've annoyed any number of
people my wife especially with my
refusal to do what I'm told
right but that's just part of how we're
wired and it's important for people to
understand when it makes sense to argue
and when it makes sense to say hey why
are we all doing this and and sometimes
you just got to go along right we like
it's very difficult for people to
separate those two
when marketing is designed to exploit
that you hear somebody say have fun
staying poor right that's not the future
of Finance
that's somebody trying to trigger your
fear of being left behind
right
well so with FCA FTX what what did they
actually promise
how do they get so many people to invest
in them how did they become this this
huge organization
well again Define huge organization
right the number of employees at FTX was
relatively limited they managed to
occupy a penthouse basically at a you
know in the Bahamas as a as an office
um so this is not a giant organization
in the classic sense
it was a giant organization in terms of
the valuation and that valuation was
pretty straightforward right this is the
future of Finance well how much is the
future of Finance work that seems like a
lot I'm going to go that's a big number
right
so do you think part of the of this of
the explosion of crypto comes from the
fact that we have a generation who are
going to struggle to get on the property
ladder things have become more expensive
wages have stagnated for the past 10 or
12 years or however long it is and they
saw crypto as an opportunity to not
necessarily gain the system but to get
rich and to find a way around those
problems it's like a lottery ticket
it was absolutely a lottery ticket but
it was a very special type of lottery
ticket
right it was a lottery ticket that
required you to do a little bit of work
to actually be able to find where to buy
it
right it was one that they could explain
how you're unique and you're special
because you've navigated these shows
you've educated yourself you've done the
work
right it's not like going to the gas
station or petrol station and buying a
lottery ticket this one your grandmother
couldn't figure out right you're special
you've figured out how to gain access to
it
of course I deserve to make a lot of
money because I'm special by the way my
mom and dad told me how special I was my
entire life and I've got the trophies to
show it
right and this just proves it it plays
in perfectly to the millennials wow you
know what my this we've talked as I said
about crypto with a lot of people but I
don't know maybe you are playing my tune
and we are Francis and I started the
show called trigonometry because we also
often refuse to go with the herd but
what everything you're saying makes
absolutely perfect sense to me and you
know why I grew up in Russia in the
early 90s uh when the Soviet Union
collapsed and you've got to understand
nobody in the Soviet Union had any
Financial Training of any kind really
and then the Soviet Union collapses and
you've got this supposed free market and
this thing comes on the screens of every
television you didn't have advertising
in the Soviet Union suddenly you're
these full color interesting scenes
playing out on your screen and these
guys talk about the system called Mmm
Triple M
uh I don't know if you're familiar with
it and basically yeah this is this was
one of the original scams if I remember
correctly in Russia right so what
happened was you know these guys would
come on your screen and go oh mate I
went down to to the thing yesterday and
I bought you know 10 Rubles worth and
now it's worth a hundred and I told my
mate and he went and and and every day
you'd be bombarded with these messages
and my dad happened to be financially
literate so every time as a young kid
I'd ask him what's going on he just said
to me it's a scam and I'd be like yeah
but my mate at school he said that his
dad bought it and he did well and my dad
would be it's a scam and this went on
for like months and eventually of course
it turned out to be a scam and every
time people talk to me about Bitcoin or
crypto and they go well look you know
this is what happened and then and I'm
always I've always got that memory in
the back of my head
um and everything you're saying just
makes so much sense because
he you know it isn't physically possible
for this to be all be true uh in the way
that people the marketing side says it
is
yeah unfortunately that
unfortunately that is that appears to be
true right I I want to be very clear
that everything I've expressed is my
opinion and my analysis of this system
and of what we have experienced for the
last several years
um
it's possible I'm wrong but I don't I I
have yet to see if you're wrong how are
you wrong if you were wrong how would
you turn out to be wrong so if I were
wrong my expectation of how I would be
wrong is a major government making an
incredible mistake and choosing to back
its currency with Bitcoin in manner in a
manner similar to what was historically
done with gold
and that's one of the reasons I spoke up
because it would be such a terrible
Choice gold actually is you know I'm
Gonna Kiss whatever fraction of your
audience I haven't already pissed off by
saying like gold itself is really just a
mineral right or a metal actually be
more accurate and it fills a relatively
unique role on the periodic table
because it's non-reactive it's non-toxic
it doesn't tarnish in other words it
doesn't oxidize right it doesn't poison
you when you pick it up like Mercury
might it doesn't you know fall through
your eat through your pocket and fall to
the floor and disappear on you right it
actually has unique properties as a
metal that can be used in that manner
just like silver just like copper just
like tin and just like nickel all of
which have been used throughout history
as metallic coinage right there's
nothing unique and special about gold
but governments chose to Peg their
currency to Gold because they wanted to
place limitations on the behavior of
individual men or Congress to radically
change monetary schedules right so the
idea was very straightforward you need
to have a set quantity of gold
um that was an important message and it
was an important limitation on the
behavior of governments particularly in
an environment in which information was
very hard to obtain right we didn't have
instantaneous Communications over the
Internet Etc
right but it also approached its
limitations as populations exploded what
that meant was one of two things either
the quantity of gold per person was
going to collapse or we were going to
decide okay we're going to break the the
message of this we fought through
basically the first 40 Years of that
with a series of deflationary episodes
basically from about 1880 until the
1920s where the global population is
exploding and yet the pop the you know
the supply of gold is not rising in a
similar fashion that led to deflationary
conditions it led to economic stagnation
it led to war-like behaviors Etc right
all sorts of things and and problems
emerge when people are forced into
unplanned and unanticipated scarcity on
those Dynamics
Bitcoin takes that Dynamic and adds an
additional wrinkle to it because Bitcoin
is programmatically limited in terms of
the number of Bitcoins that'll ever be
produced that means at some point in the
future the system has to collapse the
behavior of a Bitcoin system if you were
to build it like a video game and run it
Forward ends with one person owning all
the Bitcoin
right that's the way the system ends
almost like you know the Dynamics of
entropy in the universe
um gold had an interesting feature to it
which is if shortages of gold emerge the
price of gold Rises that encourages
people to devote resources to mining it
encourages people to devote resources to
recycling it theoretically causes people
to melt down jewelry or silverware
Etc to provide additional Supply into
the market right it encourages new
technology what actually fixed a lot of
those problems for a temporary basis was
a new form of refining gold that allowed
the treatment of types of gold that were
previously not available by the way the
same thing's happening in nickel and in
types of copper today where higher
prices are encouraging new technological
innovations
Bitcoin takes that away it robs the
system of that reward to human Ingenuity
and so in so many ways it's worse than
gold
like that's a pretty staggering
statement to make but not only is this
not the future of Finance but it is the
byproduct of people who fundamentally
did not understand what they were doing
might
the thing that always struck me with
Bitcoin as well what you're saying is
incredibly Illuminating
is the the way it was marketed is the
market the way they marketed it even the
origin story was excuse my language
[__] ridiculous there was this
Japanese inventor who who created these
Bitcoin and then he disappeared and I'm
like come on are we all like 14 years
old again
well it's again if I'm going to sell you
something right I have to be thoughtful
about what is the origin story that I'm
going to create so I'm going to tell you
that there was a man who was actually a
God who was sacrificed you know died for
our sins then came back like we have no
evidence of this we know broadly that
these things are somewhat ridiculous in
their story that there's a god-like
figure in the sky but remember we are a
society that requires that narrative we
require that explanation to get us to
turn right when the lion threatens us
right as a herd we have to follow those
behaviors as you know as a book called
The God Gene that effectively posits
that some people are wired to follow
those instructions well you have to give
them that story you have to give them
the why why are you doing this because
Satoshi Nakamoto said so and it was good
my absolutely brilliant look I'm
enjoying this conversation so much and
as Francis said Illuminating is exactly
the right word do you mind if I asked
you some
um sort of political and cultural
questions or I just because it strikes
me that you'd have an interesting take
but I understand someone in your
position might not want to talk about it
uh I mean I reserve the right not to
answer but I'm I'm happy to answer
questions no It just strikes me and I
know that am I right and thinking you've
worked with Peter Thiel as well and he
he's obviously someone who who speaks on
those issues too yeah
um yeah so I managed Peter Teal's
personal capital for a couple of years
right so I'm curious uh what you make of
what's happening in society more broadly
and is it in any way connected to some
of the stuff we've discussed today uh
you know the cultural shifts we've seen
in recent years with Advent on social
media and so on uh do you have any
thoughts on on every everything that's
happening in the cultural sphere
um so I I think they're I think
unfortunately that there are incredible
overlaps right if I draw a Venn diagram
of why this sort of thing works and
what's going on broadly that's why I
asked you I had the sense that you'd
have something to say on this yeah so so
I I do think that they are very deeply
linked
I I would actually
um you're over in the UK right is that
is that right
we encourage people to check out the
work of Ole Peters o l e
um space capital p e t r us right um
there's there's a broad School of theory
and economics that says something along
the lines of
um the market is always making the right
choice and the most important thing for
us to do is to reinforce the signals
that come from the free market and that
in turn leads to a rise in meritocratic
outcomes and an improvement of skill and
capability in society
that story has unfortunately largely
morphed into a variant of social
Darwinism those who are rich are rich
because they deserve to be so instead of
those who are rich might very well be
rich because Google fell for a story and
ended up buying out their company an
evaluation that made no difference to
Google whatsoever but provided
generational wealth to that individual
once you've achieved that generational
endowment you can then proceed to change
your behavior of investment to one that
allows you to place a series of bets
that have no individual consequence but
have option like characteristics that
allow you to enhance that wealth
um Peter brilliant in financial analysis
and cultural analysis I would argue
largely figured out that that is the
primary benefit of being involved in
Venture Capital that it allows you to
make a series of option-like bets to
potentially have a thousand times payoff
with very little consequence right
you're able to construct your portfolio
as a series of Diversified call options
that in turn each one underperforming
has very little impact on you but one
winning causes an incredible home run
but that's really only something that
can be done by somebody who has already
gotten lucky
and we fail to consider that Dynamic of
luck now the work of Olay Peters takes
in my opinion goes a step further than
the work of say pickity and sayas which
is this whole dynamic of you know R
minus G it's our R greater than G Etc
that you know wealth concentration is a
function of the Returns on Capital and
the scaling Dynamics associated with
that I don't actually think that that's
necessarily true I think what
unfortunately we've entered into is a
system in which the creation of those
bets the wealth created by those bets
and the participation in those systems
has increasingly
um moved into a narrative and Peter very
famously wrote exactly a book on this
zero to one about the power of
monopolies right starting in the 1980s
in the United States and broadly the
rest of the world tends to follow U.S
behavior on these things
for Fairly straightforward reasons it is
the world's largest economy it tends to
hold the dominant roles world's largest
military that sphere of violence it
offers is those in Iraq and Afghanistan
discovered can be quite disruptive to
the rest of the world
um you know so people broadly followed
us in this we stopped fighting
monopolies we stopped saying hey that's
actually evidence of Market power that's
a bad thing we also stopped saying guess
what you as an individual happen to win
the lottery
and therefore you should be subject to a
degree of what I would not argue are
punitive taxes but actually a
recognition that you created a windfall
by virtue of participation in the system
the people are ignoring right I mean the
fact that I invented Google and I'm
being very Broad in these terms
understand one I didn't invent Google
two I have no particular knowledge of of
the individual components associated
with that
but Google fundamentally benefits from
the protection of the intellectual
property rights that it has by the US
government it should be paying
extraordinary taxes for the windfall
that's created from the participation in
that system
and instead we've moved to an
environment in which the narrative has
been captured that says well Sergey Brin
is so brilliant and his creation of
Google was so profound that if we just
left him with more of the money he's
probably going to do it again the
evidence for that is zero and again in
fact Olay Peter's work would suggest
that the evidence in the system is is
that we are in we we have a negative
distribution for skill versus luck in
other words A system that was built
purely off of luck would do a better job
of describing the current distribution
of wealth and income in the United
States than one that was actually
matched the skill
and so I think that there's a very
fundamental flaw in our economic system
our treatment of success our resentment
of quote-unquote punitive taxes for the
extraordinarily wealthy and
well-performing because none of us
really wants to participate in society
as it's currently constructed we're all
kind of Libertarians at heart where it's
you know I'm successful because of my
capabilities but that person is
unsuccessful because of their bad
choices it's not because I'm exploiting
the system in one way shape or form
a very firm example of this I look at
the technology companies like apple
Google Etc they have been found guilty
of intentionally enforcing non-compete
contracts and non-solution
non-solicitation contracts for their
employees
right
Apple turned to in a you know in a pure
collusion Behavior turned to its
competitors and said you can't try to
hire our employees
right that impoverishes their employees
on a relative sense enriches Apple
shareholders it's behavior that is
illegal everywhere in the world
and apple paid basically sofa change as
a penalty for it right every single one
of these technology companies that I
refer to apparently does most of their
business in Ireland why because it's a
tax Arbitrage that they're able to take
advantage of right is it
almost required of their managers to
exploit that Arbitrage of course because
they should have their interests the
interest of their shareholders at heart
but as a government the United States
should not be encouraging that and the
government of the United States should
be penalizing it candidly
Mike because what you're describing
earlier on I mean that's the American
dream isn't it isn't that what we're all
buying into
you you mean uh
I'm successful because I mean you're a
failure because of you you know and I
succeed on my own merits that's the
beauty of America that's the dream a man
can pull himself up by his bootstraps
and be whatever he wants yeah and so
unfortunately the evidence for that is
increasingly untrue and the systems that
we've put in place have incurred have
increasingly encouraged extreme success
as compared to the more modest success
of the individual
right we've also moved to an environment
in which we presume that signs of
success are Goods unto themselves
right so a college degree is perceived
as the objective as compared to adequate
educational training to allow me to take
advantage of the opportunities that
exist in the environment today
right the college degree is a mechanism
increasingly for signaling I'm a member
of an Elite Class you should consider me
for this employment opportunity
right and we've taken away the market
signals that would be associated with
those degrees and the quality of those
degrees if people actually had to
contemplate the real costs associated
with it going to Harvard is an objective
in and of itself not the Harvard
Education and in fact I would
increasingly argue that the Harvard
Education is separated from the Harvard
degree
right I have a daughter who's at the
University of Pennsylvania cheating is
rampant
because kids are more focused on the
grade than the actual education
and if that's happening at the elite
schools imagine what's happening at the
second rate schools well that makes
perfect sense Mike and I suppose uh in
terms of your point about Monopoly power
it's something I've been thinking about
for a long time I imagine a big factor
in that is what we saw with Sam Bachman
freed where you're giving lots of money
to politicians to shape policy to match
what you're trying to do and I I imagine
I mean I don't have to imagine Google
and Amazon and all these other uh
powerful monopolies in their markets uh
the reason they are not losing power and
accumulating more power is that they
they know how to spread that wealth
around and make sure that they get the
right policies from government
Constantine you I couldn't have said it
better myself you were 100 correct
well on that happen you know Mike listen
I have to say it's been one of my
favorite interviews we've ever done on
trigonometry because you've just pierced
straight through a lot of the things
that I think uh confusing and perhaps
deliberately confusing for people or
certainly for me uh and uh I've really
enjoyed it and I really appreciate your
time
um as always we'll do a couple of
questions from our supporters that only
they will get to see the answers to on
our locals uh on our local site but
before we do we've got one final
question for you which is what is the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that you think we should be
um well so while I've done a lot of work
in the crypto space and and spent time
talking about that the area that I'm
most concerned actually is in what's
referred to as passive investing and the
emerging monopolies around those
behaviors
um again theories of markets theories of
economies have led people to believe
that in many situations the right choice
is not to actually try to invest not to
try to select Investments but simply to
mirror what everybody else is doing
the theories that underpin that are at
least if not significantly more flawed
than the theories that describe the
economy I was referring earlier to the
work of Olay Peters was referred to as
the efficient market hypothesis this
idea that all information is out there
and simply you know mimicking everybody
else's Behavior
allows me to participate without running
the risk that I underperform right
um unfortunately markets don't work that
way markets are not driven by
information markets are driven by
transactions there is no such thing as a
passive investor the theory behind
passive investing describes passive
investing as someone who never transacts
well the firms that are engaged in
passive investing and index type
investing transact every single day
Vanguard BlackRock between the two of
them received somewhere around three
billion dollars worth of inflows every
single day
their behaviors are increasingly
structurally affecting the signals and
behavior of the investment markets that
we see simple theories often decry that
as being tied to the Federal Reserve or
other central banks increasingly those
models are at odds with what I would
describe as the reality of how markets
behave from a structural framework and
that actually creates extraordinary
risks for us as a society because when
Retirement Systems fail and ultimately
that's where this system is heading it's
creating a liquidity crisis that I would
argue is accelerating as we speak
that crisis almost always signals the
end of democracy is Constantine you saw
this happen in Russia when the pension
system fails that's when you move to an
authoritarian system
wow well it's been a happy interview
Mike listen I we really appreciate your
time it's been absolutely fantastic if
people want to hear more of your
thoughts is there a place they can go to
do that
um I mean the the most disappointing
version of that would be to go to my
Twitter feed which is at Prof plum99
proof Plum 99
confusingly I look like the character
vasini from The Princess Bride
um uh before anyone asks one I never
anticipated being well followed on
Twitter and two the reason I chose
foscini is because I constantly try to
remind myself that the perception that
you're the world's smartest man is
doomed to lead to your own demise in
some ridiculous game where you didn't
really understand the rules of the game
that were being played
um you can find a little bit more of my
stuff by Googling these types of
podcasts and interviews occasionally
I'll write on my medium profile and the
last thing is is that if you're
interested in very esoteric discussions
around Market structure and options
um the derivative Dynamics around that
you can check out the work of tier one
alpha
t-i-e-r-a-l-f-a-a-l-p-h-a.com which I
wrote a morning note for
fantastic well I'll be sure to follow
you on Twitter right after this uh stay
with us because we'll ask you a couple
of questions for our locals but thank
you for being here and thank you guys
for watching and listening we will be
back very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one oral show all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
I believe the prevalence of successful
scams in the crypto space is indicative
of the individuals who are drawn to it
and therefore is indicative of the lack
of real value of Bitcoin or do you say
in response
[Music]